guitar
tattoos are
we are officially live with episode
number 76 we got 24 more to go for
episode number 100 they say the first
hundred
you'll learn how to actually do a
podcast so we're still learning all
right we're still learning
gerard tom have you guys ever been on
together or no you've always been
somebody
else phil heath yeah once or twice no
it's never just been tom and i just this
is the first time to do it
it's very interesting let's do it very
attractive okay so uh
crazy stories crazy we have a lot of
crazy stews we got anti-sex beds the
only picks making as if these olympians
cannot figure out who would have sex
they found one good story for their own
base space jam which i have to say i
watch with the kids on sunday
and i know you watch it last night have
you seen it yet or no no i was just
curious at what point did you walk out
okay so so i'm going to give you very
clear
you know description of what happened
with us when we watched okay
cool uh probably one of the most
uncomfortable
interviews i've ever seen in my life was
on cnn with brian stelter i think we
have to show that
yeah it's something we have to talk
about and folks i want you to make a
decision whether you like it or not or
if it's fair but
the guest was not holding back and it
was disturbing to say the least
elon musk says there's no way in the
world
tesla would survive without him as a ceo
we'll see if you guys agree with that i
got some thoughts on that
millennials are breaking away from their
desk jobs and working remotely in places
like
mexico out of all the places right i i
guess if i was
20 years old 18 years old would i want
to work at a
you know from a home with my friends in
mexico at masatlan
or yeah probably wouldn't be a bad idea
right yeah totally in right
jeff bezos is going to space literally
right now okay you want to check to see
if he's made it out there yet or not
let's just
keep checking on that god willing he'll
stay there
megan fox uh someone you're not a fan of
you have a very hard time uh uh
hard is the key word yeah so you and
megan foxy you know
uh gerard is is infatuated the right
word i would drink her bath water
they okay that's enough who said that he
said i would treat her
as the great kevin durant once said i
would drink her bath water
maybe actually use that line yeah yeah
conservative porn star
brandy love 48 is kicked out of florida
republican conference for high school
kids
because outraged parents complained okay
we'll cover that we'll cover that as
well
and then bill burr on cnn they're effing
treasonous
unamerican pieces of [ __ ] i mean he just
didn't hold back this is
bill burr saying that about the media i
mean you have to if it's gotten to a
point where you have to kind of hold
back from saying how you really feel
that that filter is gone right now cnn
only makes news when people destroy them
on air
megan fox bill burr in the same episode
this is like
i can't believe it all right let's start
off with uh elon musk i say i see i say
we're going to elon musk
minute and a half can we see it can we
at least take a look at it let me read
that why don't you pull that up pat on a
scale of one to ten
how scared is bezos right now i say he's
out of 40.
i bet he is you think so i bet he's
freaking out this sounded good
you know a while ago when he was talking
to laura and his girl about doing it and
impressing her but now that he's
buckling in come on man
this space cowboy nerd is freaking out i
guarantee you
his ex-wife's thinking i just should
have held on a little longer
why did i settle for half
[Music]
people are only interested in this for
the same reason they're interested in
nascar in the special olympics
you seriously think that you seriously
think people are saying they're hoping
something happens
uh yeah i think so man did you see what
tulsi gabbard say well
do us a favor and stay there
oh i love me some tulsi tell us he's
like loser favorite kai can you pull up
a video so we can see it on twitter okay
is this it
is this literally live right now is that
what it looks like yeah that's what's in
the cap
yeah that's it it's very phallic this
guy's taking a dildo into space
open it up open it up open it up
wow blue over here
is there an audio or no it's real for
basils right now oh my god
do you guys remember the end of austin
powers one when it goes to the outer
space
hey this takes guts to get into that
johnson
[Music]
that's an amazing view how many flat
earthers are tweeting right now that
this is staged
okay so this is gonna last definitely
watching this look at he he even put the
testes on there what's going on bezos
so they're gonna burn all the fuel and
then that's when it starts coming down
it's going to go 62 miles up
yeah what do you mean it's gonna always
feel it starts coming down that's the
way it goes bro
460. it's a cool sight
you think he's worried gerard do you
think he's worried
i don't know he's he's he's got a he's
inside of a building that's strapped to
a nuclear bomb that's going
a thousand miles an hour if you're not
worried you're probably not human you
actually think he's worried
i think so i mean this is unchartered
territory i mean
you can't prepare for this all the way
so i think a little bit
i think there's a reason why he brought
people he loves the most who
who's in there with him let me just read
who's in there with them let me uh
all right bezos page four this is
actually happening the richest man in
the world is out there he's in that
capsule right there
do you think the outside is ribbed for
her pleasure or
now gerard you either need to find
a girl you need some help buddy it's
it's
somebody we thought it was
gerard's got adam beat right now adam if
you're watching this
buddy rockets for your entire life have
looked like that just so you know that
it's your mind that's screwed up right
now that all you see is a dildo
that's just a rocket i can't think of
one rocket i've ever seen in my life
with a mushroom tip
now it's jeff bezos turn to make history
with flight into space this is nbc news
story
just over a week uh after richard
branson flew to the edge of space fellow
billionaire jeff bezos is set for
similarly
high stakes trip abroad his own rocket
but online keep it up kai
keep it up unlike virgin galactic unity
space the new shepard rocket and capsule
fly
autonomous autonomously without pilots
on board so there's no pilots on board
no no so they've just hit their max
speed it's leveling off that's three
times the speed of sound
this is where the guy jumped out is this
like the same height where that guy
jumped well they're 200 000 212 look at
that
they're up there man beautiful day
unreal okay slowing down what is the
practical
all jokes aside what is the practical
act you know
what why are they going through this
billion dollar space race they don't
they don't they don't
tax in space so it's like you can go
live there for 181 days
you know you're saving so much money are
they going to look to mine on the moon
resources they're gonna charge 200 grand
a flight for these things going forward
200g by the way did you know that the
guy that paid 28 million to go up with
these guys yeah backed out
we didn't go they had to go they had to
go to plan b they had to bring the 18
year old kid
that was on the next one i'm sure he
pulled an ashton kutcher
and his wife told him you're not going
that's what happened with kutcher
what happened with that ashley kutcher
already paid for the next mission with
branson
already paid for it a couple hundred
grand and mila said you're not going and
so he's not
so i said dude where's your man card i
mean come on he's handing him literally
mila said you're not going and he's not
going they had a conversation she didn't
feel comfortable with it so he backed
out he's not doing it if you gotta lose
your man card to anybody mila kunis
isn't the same person
best mila kunis movie uh best mila kunis
movie
has to be forgetting i mean i don't
think there's anything please time out
friends with benefits with justin
timberlake better than forgetting sarah
marshall
principal benefits is good but it's not
and it's not sarah marshall let me tell
you sarah marshall
is is maybe it's got to go into the
smithsonian it's one of those unique
movies
inside of you yeah i'd say it'd say no
one mentioned black swan
oh it was a good movie too did you see
that one yeah yeah so let's see here
several other milestones may be set on
this trip joining basis will be one
passenger who stands to become the
oldest person to reach space and another
person who's the youngest
wally frank 82 is a former test pilot
who was one
of the mercury 13 women who underwent
training
in 1960s to demonstrate that women could
meet nasa standards for its astronaut
corpse
at 18 the dutch teenager oliver damon
could become the youngest astronaut
rounding out the four-person crew is
jeff bezos's brother
mark that's right he's going up with his
bro you know i think the scariest point
for bezos is when that parachute opens
and you're dropping then that's a
that's a long way to come down
so are they going to be right now
they're going to release the video from
inside after the fight
some of them spinning around is going to
come later so right now all you hear is
them talking
that's awesome he doesn't sound nervous
though no he doesn't man
he doesn't
let me ask you a question if you're
watching this if you're watching this
and if you could afford it
thumbs up two hundred thousand dollars
you'd spend to go there
thumbs down i could care less about
going up there smash thumbs up
if you would spend if you had the money
200 000 wasn't anything to you
can you lower my audio by like 10 if if
money wasn't an issue to you would you
spend 200 000
to go to space thumbs up thumbs down i
could care less about going to space
what's yours thumbs down i i don't like
heights number one okay and and i don't
need thrills i i just don't need them i
don't like i don't need them i
i get thrills other ways i don't need to
manufacture them by going up into space
i'm not
into it two hundred thousand dollars
i'd spend two hundred thousand dollars
to be weightless i think yeah
how much could gerrard bench in space
five
million pounds unlimited lift that uh
rocket
but would you want to do that would you
want to ah dude yeah i'm an adrenaline
junkie for sure
so you would yeah i i think so kai yeah
what's your what
david i want you to think about malin i
want you to think about kai would you go
000 money's not an issue i would you
would i wouldn't be one of the first
people to do it but like
i'd be maybe like 10 rounds in
i'd be you would do it yeah you could
care less not only i could care like i
hate roller coasters
they freak me out i don't think i can
make it i just don't like the high
school you'd be the guy turning around
coming back down
oh you're damn right i'd be raising my
hand is it is it the rule it doesn't
escort me down
i think the audio is very loud all in
all so lower it 10
total it's a little too loud if you ask
me yeah even for us okay is it the
roller coaster that freaks you out tom
or is it the the meth head running
the roller coaster see i i think i i got
a little more uh
if it's just commercialized and it's
like a flight let's do it but if it's
like this crazy
tight spaceship i'll sit this one out
how funny would that be though and like
if this was so old hat in 50 years that
they just have like old carnies running
running the rockets into space yeah
there's like one guy with a
with a marble red hanging out the side
of his mouth like hey you ready to go up
to mars but
would you would you do it or no uh yeah
i would also have to wait for a couple
runs
but i i mean i like roller coasters and
adrenaline but
that's risking your whole life yeah i
agree
you're going you get motorcycles i would
i would i mean to me
but i will tell you i don't like tight
spaces i'm not a fan of tight spaces but
i would go so
okay so it landed back uh that's insane
then it came right back on that landing
spot isn't it
it looks kind of burnt fully it needs a
car wash that's
so it's coming back down man that's it
yep well now they're on the way down i
think they got like three minutes where
they get to do cartwheels and stuff
you know so we can get this in in clear
6k
hd but every freaking ufo video that we
see
is like a dot matrix from from an old
school like game boy like come on it's a
hell of a steady cam they have
yeah i mean look there you go
if you would have said years ago one day
there's going to come a time where you
can go to space for 200 grand or pop
i actually think this is going to be a
business model and i think
the the next thing is who can can you
lower the audio at this point
i think the next thing is how creative
they get with this
meaning what else is gonna happen you
know now it's a publicity stunt now it's
gonna be like who's gonna be in it what
celebrity
are they going to be able to pull a
kardashian a rock a
ronaldo a messy somebody that's going to
want to go like you got to market this
thing for people to say i want to go do
it
is a youtuber going to go on there make
a video about it and get like
you know 200 million views and oh my
gosh you got to do it like at a
discounted rate
what what's going to be next here's
what's going to be the next thing
join the 30 mile high club and you call
up there
you see that could you see some point
you just fired gerrard up right now
now you're in it for sure it's paid by
the hour i like it
yeah okay folks we were able to get so
by the way just so you know most people
want to go everybody wants to go i mean
it's a nine to one yeah i know who wants
to go and who doesn't want to go nine to
one who says i'm willing to go
versus those who don't want to go 200
000 actually seems like not a lot of
money so you're telling me eight people
that's
eight hundred thousand for for eight
people times eight people no no
four times for rocket launch i can't
believe it it's got to be that's got to
be more expensive to send that thing up
i don't know maybe they're going to be
bigger when they go up maybe this is the
the test module if my
do you think you're allowed more than
two bags or
[Laughter]
american airlines they imagine if they
start doing that you'll
you'll take off maybe you'll go to space
when we good and damn well feel like
they had to turn that flight around
because someone didn't have their mask
on
all right let us let us give you a
softball story here
here let's give a story to gerard kai
can we let's let this thing let this
thing keep going
in the background we'll see what's going
on here as we get up must said it's uh
space garbage is supposed to be like
like no all jokes aside like space
garbage is going to be a big industry
because they have so much stuff up there
they have to protect their their
satellites so going up there and
cleaning the the space garbage that's in
orbit is going to be like a big
the stuff he thinks about like who wakes
up in the morning saying i need to start
a waste management company in space
there it is they just landed michael
franzis yeah
wouldn't that be funny if a martian got
out they could commandeered the thing
different we come to take over the
planet jeff is probably gonna get out
with his famous smile and his laugh
you know his life alex jones is watching
this getting angry patrick yeah
don't come from outer space i told you
the internet's really already been here
reptilian no that's david ike all right
let me let me
let me cover the musk story and then
we'll see if this guy comes out and what
he's going to say about it
musk tells solarcity trial that tesla
would die if he wasn't ceo this is a
reuters story elon musk insisted in
court that tesla's board controls
the company but also said the electric
vehicle would would die
if he wasn't a chief executive as he
ended his first day of testimony on
monday in defense of the tesla's 26th
and acquisition of soldier city
the lawsuit by union pension funds and
asset managers alleges the celebrity ceo
strong armed tesla's board of directors
into depleting
the company's asset with a 2.6 billion
all stock deal for solar city the ceo at
the time owned
a roughly 22 the cob in illinois 22
stake
in both tesla and solar city which was
founded by his cousins
and some tesla shareholders alleged the
deal was aimed at bailing out musk's
investment in the solar panel company
kicking off a two-week trial
in wilmington delaware musk testified
that he has tried very hard
not to be the ceo of tesla but i have to
or frankly tesla is going to die
yeah thoughts i think he's got to be
really really pissed off and it comes
through in his comments right here like
the nerve of these shareholders what
have i done to you
with your with the wealth that you've
attained through tesla stock
and you want to try to hang me on this
little technicality that's what great
visionaries do they take shortcuts every
now and then
they figure out ways to do it because
they got the guts to do it they think
they can get away with it
you know what this trial is interesting
he's had a verbal teta tet with the uh
the
other lawyer in this civil trial i mean
they went at it in day one
but i believe musk 100 that he would not
want to be tesla's ceo anymore and i'll
tell you why he's not having fun
i just don't think it's a fun job for
him anymore there's a lot of issues
you know just dealing with what he has
to do maybe having the sec on the
horizon now too
you know a shortage of supply you can't
really get a tesla if you want one right
now
and he sees these other billionaires
having fun
flying off into space and he's got a
space company too but he can't spend any
time on that because it's dealing with
issues and problems
he'd give up tesla in one second if he
could but it would fall apart yeah and
and he's been infiltrated by some far
left proxies
off you know that he's hired people that
have turned out to be political
operatives against them
and they get in specifically to try to
convince all his employees to unionize
and he's he said he's like why the
second you you unionize you lose all
your tesla stock why would any of you
want to do this like
so um look man i'll tell you this
i am a shareholder in tesla and i
uh i i've put my deposit down i support
elon musk every chance i get
elon musk is either ousted or sells i
sell
i'm out 100 i don't invest in tesla i
invest in elon musk
and i think that that i represent a
majority of those shareholders and i
think he knows that
and he said on multiple occasions he's
like guys threaten me again
i'll take this company private just one
more time just one more time don't let
me do what i want to do with my own
company and i will pull the plug i don't
need the money i will take this thing
private i'm going to give you a
completely different perspective
from what you guys just said here he's
playing with fire
and here's what i mean by he's playing
with fire um
so so a a company is like a government
you have to realize each company is like
a government it's got the people in the
middle
who are the best people to bounce ideas
off of because they'll be like okay let
me think about it and then they're
reasonable
yeah i don't know about that i don't
know if i like that idea and they'll
sincerely tell you
i don't know if i like that i'm talking
about his fellow executives yeah i'm
talking executives yeah i'm talking like
board executive people you're working
with so you got the c-suites you got the
board right
there's people on the board that are
like yeah you know that's we should
actually consider you know what why
don't we have a couple people run some
numbers here and see what that looks
like if we were to make a half a billion
dollar investment in 2.00 right
then there are those that no matter what
he says they're going to say no to
then then there are those that no matter
what he says they're going to say yes to
right so then there's gridlock on the
board when there's gridlock in the board
the founder the driver the ceo loses
his or her mind when there's gridlock
this is why you're talking 51
rule or if your name is uh mark
zuckerberg
you keep it at 26 and you're out of
delaware which means you still have 2x
amount of votes which is 52
so you can still have control no matter
what anybody else says even though
you're not a 51
owner you can still set it up that way
to have the influence right
but at the same time you have to know
that the no people
the people that are just automatic knows
they're typically the ones that are more
pro-government
and more you know uh uh you know
regulations some of that
yes they're bureaucrats right so they're
a little bit uh afraid of what could
happen
so they're one step away if you piss me
off
i may not be able to do anything to you
but i know how to make your life a
living hell
okay which means going to who oh they're
litigators they go right there
they go not to buddy it's in the sec it
go back to making his life a living hell
so
and these are people that he put on his
board that would do that not necessarily
he put on his sport so
he can nominate some people to be on his
board others can nominate to be on his
board you don't necessarily have
everybody you choose to be on your board
i don't understand how that works can
you give me like a two minute on that
okay so let's just say you come in and
you say i'm gonna put a i'm gonna raise
a billion i'm gonna race
let's start a small company okay okay
it's
it's it's the two of you start a small
company together
and but you're getting two point like
even yesterday i'm interviewing the
dave's killer bread you know dave's
killer great i'm interviewing the guy
right
they start the business they go from
doing 200 loaves a week to doing 500 000
loaves a week
he says we don't have money to because
we keep running out of money we don't
know what to do
so then eventually flower foods comes in
and buys them out and now they're doing
10 million a week
loaves of bread per week he gets 275
million dollar cash deal
but out of the 275 million dollar cash
deal he only got 33 million dollars
why poor guy here's why here's why
because
when you're growing you don't have funds
so you have to go grow and raise capital
so you come let's just say to me and you
say pat we need about 10 million dollars
i said i'll give you 10 million dollars
great in return
i want you to have a seven-man board
seat out of your seven-man board seat i
want three seats
okay that's how it works gotcha so you
say
okay so the four-board seat it's gonna
be what you tom and you pick whoever
else the two are
and i bring my three the go with the
money guy
is to maybe win one more board seat if i
win one more board seat you can come up
with all the craziest ideas you want but
that doesn't necessarily mean
that your ideas are gonna hit it's like
a corporate filibuster in other words
kind of like what's going on right now
in senate or congress where it's like a
you know blockade or nothing really gets
man that's kind of a deal with the devil
so you need the money to run your
business but then they take your
business
and yeah from you yes so it's not just
to share so many times people think when
you're
bringing a money person in you're
worried about the you know the equity
you're giving up
no it's the control you're giving up so
okay tasmanian devils
like elon musk don't do well with
control
but he has to understand you're not
worth 50 million
you're not worth 20 million you're worth
to 200 billion on a monday you could be
worth 120 friday could be worth 200
billion
the gdp of a small island it's
absolutely the gdp
of a good sized island right okay
so if he goes in the offensive the way
he is
he has to know all the money in the
world even if he's worth a trillion
dollars the government doesn't give a
[ __ ] how much you're worth
regulation has the government has a
history
of ruining people's lives who have a lot
of money that think they can open their
mouth and say
anything he has to understand that and
he has to make some friends
or he's going to be willing to go all in
if he does go all
in if he does go all in there are way
too many people that would team up
against him there's a country that
doesn't like him too much you know what
that country is called
he went in thinking he can make a deal
with them and what did they all of a
sudden do
oh yeah yeah bring your cars over here
we'll do a deal with you we learn
everything about what your cars are you
know what get out of here we're good we
got we got to figure that out that
country's name is
happy happy 100th birthday that's right
that's right so egalitarian
all i'm saying to all i'm saying about
what he's doing right now and by the way
another part i'll give you another part
when you say the company would flop
without me
okay now imagine you're the cmo of that
company
you're busting the ass working 80 hours
a week the ceo says
the company would be nothing without me
do you really want to work for that ceo
well keep in mind they don't do
marketing though so they wouldn't make
that on the market a form of marketing
is putting your stores on the malls and
that's
that's a form of marketing okay a form
of marketing is that video advertising
no no i know that but a formal marketing
is you make a video for instagram
youtube twitter that's all marketing
right
imagine you're his cfo imagine you're
his cro imagine your ceo
imagine you're his president and the guy
says you guys are not going to do
anything without me
you think there's cohesiveness on the
team right now i think there's a certain
part of a rift going on right now on
that team because
there's only so much c-suite executives
can take you to say dude i'm going to go
somewhere else to be appreciated so
again it's for the board is forcing him
to pin himself against
his executives it's not a good level i
agree with you that i
i they're probably pissed off and that
they don't feel validated and worth
you know what they feel they are when he
says that but i also believe it's true
there are some companies that the the
the leader is so dynamic
and so remember when they have i would
say it's not true okay
keep going remember when we remember
when they literally work for one of
those companies
hey remember when they had the situation
maybe two years ago
where they weren't producing the model
the the e or whatever and he had to go
in there and sleep on the couch and work
20 hours a day
for like a month and a half to keep it
going i mean he basically saved the
company right there yeah
so it's it's a tug of war because he's
right and he is going to lose some good
executives along the way but i don't
know
don't you think that he thinks if i lost
tesla i'll just go build another one
but but but here's the saying buddy like
this is this is how i
again listen elon musk's elon musk i
admire this man for what he's done and
god knows he's done more good for the
world than bad so we need
we we have to keep a guy like this same
to keep producing and solving many big
problems
because he vibrates at a level other
people don't but this is the one part to
keep in mind when you're good
talk about it promote it yeah if you're
good at something but when you're great
you don't talk about it other people do
yeah other people do you michael jordan
never went around talking about how
great he is
lebron lebron has a different story but
michael jordan
just went and showed you greatness and
then you said this
man is great elon musk is great you
don't need to tell us
we know already are great all right how
about you just said something you got to
keep him got to keep himself sane
he's going in there he's working 18-hour
days he says he only works he only
sleeps four hours how long can you keep
that up before there's burnout
how long i like just because you're an
executive doesn't mean you're not a
human and that's just
one of those kind of likes there has to
be like we expect these people to
function at such a high level you got a
ferrari best car in the world you keep
it in the red for too long the engine
experience
i don't disagree but here's what happens
just so you know what happens if you're
redlining it too much you know what
happens
happened to me a handful of times in my
career when i'm when i'm pushing too
hard
and again this scares the hell out of
some people when i'm pushing too hard my
body just shuts down
you go to the emergency room you get
iv'd up and people tell you know your
body's purely on exhaustion one time i
was on a two-week
road trip visiting all these offices and
i was going on two to four hours of
sleep a night
it's just you know very difficult to
when i came back
on two o'clock in the morning i don't
even know what's going on my body i went
to the hospital
and next thing you know they checked me
out they put the iv in me they said sir
i said is it my heart
it says no your heart is fine
everything's functioning well your
body's just telling you are freaking
exhausted is what it is this happens to
athletes who are pushing the limits this
happens to military this happens to
business people
and he's testing by the way eventually
something's going to happen to his
health
and that's what gets them like you know
when uh a lot of these people
business people they hit a wall and then
there's a health issue and they're like
i better start paying attention to it
he's going to pay attention to it as
well
but i think for him you're not going to
slow him down like is someone going to
sit this guy down and say
hey elaine i think you need to get seven
hours of sleep to reach rem he ain't
gonna listen to nobody no if you don't
even think it's that though
i'm talking about like when i get tired
you know i my patience is the first
thing that goes
and this might be something tweeting two
o'clock in the morning after 48 hours of
work and where he just doesn't have
patience
he just doesn't have the patience you
know what i'm saying for me when i get
when i get worn down
you get the physical that you're talking
about but the mental drain is even worse
where i just i don't have the patience
for something
small that i would have been able to be
like all right no worries about it we'll
talk about it tomorrow
when i was functioning at a level i
should be functioning at 11 hours later
i'm just like dude why would you even
ask me something so stupid like
you snap at something like that the
patience goes i think if you read
between these lines with his quotes too
i think he feels trapped
because he's built i don't disagree yeah
i think he's built such a behemoth he
wishes he had that exit button he knows
he can't leave he knows that come
he hey it's physically impossible for
him to leave that company
but if he could and that's why he's
doing saturday night live and that's why
he's going over to richard branson's
yeah you know cheap kitchen
the night of his flight by the way
there's some great memes with
with musk and branson in that kitchen
together but he would he would exit
stage left if he could i i don't
i don't disagree with that as well
listen sometimes remember the last dance
when michael's going through his back to
back to back then his father then the
whole thing is just like i just want to
get away
guy would be in a hotel remember that
one scene we're just sitting in the
whole term just waiting for the game
just doesn't look happy you look
miserable like you're like you wanted
this your entire life now
but dennis rodman i need three days in
vegas
he had to come back he had to come back
and figure out a way how to deal with
media
and do it in a way where it worked for
him the second time around if you ever
watch michael first time around media
second time around media it's as if that
year and a half got him
to straighten out his relationship with
the media and he learned how to deal
with them
i think elon's gotta you know step away
yeah i think he's got a
maybe six month hiatus you just gotta go
away bro just go do your thing spend
some time with your kids with your wife
with whatever you wanna do
keep it low key figure yourself i can
come back out because the way he's going
right now
i i think he's gonna they're not going
to let him go at the pace he's going
right now they're just not
he's going to show up and he's got two
other big companies that he's trying to
run as well like if he takes some time
away from tesla he still has you know
the the rocket company and then he's
still got his solar company and then he
still has his boring company and
trying to save the world he's a rock
star man you know he's a he's the kind
of guy
that a thousand years from now if we
don't have armageddon happen with
dinosaurs showing back up people are
going to read about elon musk
and elon musk is going to be a
rockefeller chase type of a guy he's a
once-in-a-lifetime generation type of
guy we gotta
appreciate the guy when he's here so uh
okay let's talk about space jam let's go
to space jam okay i'm gonna talk about
space jam and then uh we'll see what the
article has to say page nine if you
wanna go to it
uh and then we'll uh we'll we'll cover
that and you said by the way tom you
said you've seen it as well right i have
not seen it you have not seen it okay
lebron james sends message to haters as
space jam takes over box office this is
a new york post story
lebron james sent a message to the world
as his new film takes over the box
office james took to twitter to link an
article stating
a space jump a new legacy is set to
finish the weekend at number one with a
projected 32 million dollars opening
beating up black widow hi haters
james world cup can you pull up this
twitter tweet please hi haters the
sequel to 1996 michael jordan let's
space jam pulled in more than 30 million
dollars on friday despite poor reviews
the
movie which reportedly cost 150 million
to make is also available on hbo max
other hoop stars appear in the space jam
sequel include anthony davis damian
lillard
diana tarusi and klay thompson so
having said that gerard you watched it
last night tell us about it
space jam the original space channels
are my favorite movies and in fairness
i'm not a lebron james fan but i thought
okay
listen it's a kid's movie they can they
can
polish his image right and all this
thing was the first 15 minutes were the
most
self-aggrandizing arrogant thing i've
ever seen in my life juxtaposed it
against the original space jam
where the first 10 minutes 15 minutes
were michael jordan joking about himself
it was self-deprecating right there just
the self-awareness
of what you need to know lebron james
being called king and
you know showing why he's the greatest
thing in the world you know versus
michael jordan cracking on himself
right off the bat that's all you need to
know about the two guys and
the way that they maintain their brand
but i watched it i got all the way
through it
and it had some unbelievably talented
people don cheadle
ryan coogler the the animation was was
terrific
killed it there was like seven jokes and
i i sat there after
you know an hour and a half and i felt
like i was in like some sort of mental
gulag i have no idea why i did this
90 minutes of my life on this and i said
you know i i'm not
positive if this is true but
i think i can make an argument that
casey anthony is a better mother
than space jam is a movie i think i'm
not positive i didn't care for it
i'm not i'm not i'm not really in the
the you know i don't want i don't like
ripping other artists and stuff like
that man and you know 150 million
dollars some unbelievable guys
that's great but this was the single
worst thing i think i've ever
this was the room bad this was
oh high mark level bad this was
oh man i don't even like this should be
this should be classified as a war crime
this thing was horrible how they're
showing this to children bad to you
oh my god now gerard doesn't have
children right so it's not like you were
sitting there with a couple kids that
might have all right
dug it so you have any thoughts on it i
have some thoughts on it number one i
think this is all spin
right i think i think lebron can come
out hey haters scoreboard but you know
what if this was a normal times that's
not a good debut
32 million is not a good friday through
sunday debut as a matter of fact
it's right up there with robert downey
jr's doolittle all right
he did the exact same damn thing in 2020
and that was considered one of the
probably the biggest flop of downey's
career so a
you have limited releases right now okay
there's just not that many movies
there's not that many options out there
b you know if you compare it to what
michael debuted with what
jerry maguire was out at that time i
mean there were some big big movies and
some competition
i give lebron credit shows up at the
finals with his own bottle of tequila
that he's promoting
and he's got the movie if he was in the
finals this thing would have done even
better
right because that's a a running
commercial that was the plan though if
you look at the date when it came out
in the finals yeah so i think i think
this is a little bit of a disappointment
but all in all it's going to do well
it's going to do a couple hundred
million worldwide especially when you
bring in the streaming numbers he just
doesn't know how to have fun he's like
the least fun human being like the dude
is a-rod man like he's like so
image conscious he's just everything
comes off as so canned
you were right i felt like i was
watching lebron james propaganda this
was not so
a fun movie so here's what happened with
me i go back to the tweet that i sent to
you like go go to that
so here's what i said i responded back
to him i said jordan versus lebron space
jam space jam 1 mj budget 80 million box
office 250.2 million
in 1997 not including inflation no
streaming no social media space jam 2
budget 150 box office it would need to
do 471 million dollars to match space
jam
one no hater here just simple data right
that's what i respond okay
so now two hours after this tweet goes
out i take the kids to go watch it
so it's myself and the kids and mario
and carol so we go to watch to
we'll go to watch the the the what do
you call it the movie
and for me the first 15 minutes just
look
pretty much what you said it looked like
a documentary it didn't like look like a
movie it looked like how great he is his
highlight reel
all that stuff right and then the story
starts and it's the story of father
son and you know he's forced him to be a
basketball player this guy's a gamer and
you know hey
i i saw that part the emotional
connection about a father trying to get
his kids to be like him it's a very
difficult position
it's lebron james this guy is the
greatest basketball player in the world
as of three years ago right i mean he's
changed the last two or three years
the greatest basketball player around
the world so the storyline was great so
i asked my kids afterwards not gonna lie
to you the last 45 minutes i was knocked
out it was the best sleep i had in a
long time
i'm not not to take shots at the movie
just so everybody knows i knock out
fifty percent of movies i watch
this is not like it's a space champ
thing it's a pbd what's the theater fall
shout out to jp series theater was not
only full they clapped at the end people
stood up screaming they loved the
storyline okay
i asked my kids what do you think about
it they like space jam two more than one
but they don't know like the whole
history and all this other stuff they
don't look at it from that standpoint
my boys related to the story that has to
do with them and their father that's all
they talked about
because my son says he wants to be a
scientist so he's not trying to be and i
always tell him buddy i don't want you
to do what your daddy does what do you
want to do right so to them
it was kind of like that connection they
made with the story i thought the story
was
phenomenal is what the story was the
writer is an armenian
writer by the way the guy who wrote the
script as an armenian writer i thought
the
script was great i thought don was
freaking insane
he's done cheating he just crushed it i
thought lebron
is not an actor i thought lebron's
commercials the first year he came out
were better than the acting he did in
this movie
uh and then at the same time there's
just a part of me that you know
i go back and i think about a couple
things here again
high haters numbers here i mean what
what what do you buddy
first of all michael wouldn't do that
here's the other part here's the other
part if i'm lebron james
why didn't kobe bryant ever do space jam
too mm-hmm
what are you doing space jam 2 yeah like
what is the idea of doing space jam 2
i don't even if i'm his marketer if i'm
his right hand guy
and i'm sitting there saying nothing
about your brand has ever been linked to
michael jordan
kobe's was kobe was trying to be like
mike
kobe's the gatorade commercial like mike
i want to be
like mike i want to be out you know the
whole thing yes kobe was trying to be
mine
there's nothing about lebron james
that's like he's trying to be my other
than the number
not his game not no well it used to be
six until michael said you know he took
a shot at lebron saying no one is bigger
than the nba and michael j
lebron's like i'll take 23 right now
lebron do your own movie what's space
jam so i don't understand that concept
like
are we supposed to expect giannis to do
space jam three in about ten years
i don't know what i think my i think
lebron secretly thought he was going to
do a better movie than michael i think
he wanted to one-up him
and i think that was dangerous you know
by the way they're also tooting their
horn about like i said this is all spin
you know with movie numbers that's all
it is they were coming out and saying we
beat black widow well black widow's been
out for three weeks and it did 80
million on their first weekend yeah
right so there's no comparison there
whatsoever i will give lebron
credit for one thing it's not easy
acting on a green screen
and with animated characters i mean if
you're not a trained actor and then you
have to
try to pull that off and make it seem
real i'm gonna go check it out dash
wants to see it
neither was mike by the way neither was
mike was yeah michael
with ryan coogler advising you and 150
million on the
on the warner lot you don't think it's
uh something you could pull off no i'm
sorry i'm sure he can
but i'm just saying it's not the easiest
if you're watching this who watched it
if you watched it did you like it did
you not like it just out of curiosity
you know if you if you if you've seen it
and you liked it put thumbs up
if you watched it and you didn't like it
put thumbs down maybe give us a score
out of 10 rotten tomatoes i think's got
a 4-2 or 4-3 i don't know what the score
is
yeah imdb is a 4-3 here this thing of
ours just posted 4-3 on imdb
what's your score out of 10 if you
actually watch it and right next to it
write down i'm a lebron james fan or i'm
not a lebron james fan
well i mean look you know i like that he
set the bar so low for success because
my dumb internet videos have got like 34
35 million views so uh
hi haters like i'm i'm crushing it i'm
killing it man
so thanks lebron for that you know what
else i saw regarding lebron you know
he's got that entertainment company
spring hill entertainment
i heard that they're looking at a
potential billion dollar
exit out of that thing like literally
like there's going to be a billion
dollar offer for that i mean yeah him
and
exit though well i mean because
someone's going to buy it out or invest
into it or something not to pivot but
did you see omaha productions with
peyton and eli manning yeah yeah the the
massive contract they just signed with
espn they're gonna they're gonna like
an alternative monday night football
broadcast dude for espn
which is awesome how much it was the
undisclosed but they've got like 10-year
contract
to contin basically they're going to be
the production company for espn plus
they're going to be the premium
production company what's the number do
we do you have the data we made a number
200 million 300 million a billion it
would have i would i would
posit it's a hundred million somewhere
okay so like 10 million out of your top
of the numbers what we're talking about
okay so mark the mark said he's eight
for ten
kids seven out of ten i don't like
lebron whack one out of ten
and you know this other guy's a lebron
fan put it down uh
also it is what it is did lebron take
like three shots in the movie by the way
like i don't like sleeping i'm a soccer
fan
and yeah lebron played basketball for
two seconds in them he literally
played basketball for like a second yeah
it was barely any basketball so i fell
asleep after the tasmanian devil took
the score from whatever was to 450 470.
i knocked out they didn't miss much
okay hey you can see space jam 3 with
brony james yeah
in ten years okay if i'm anyone's market
or if i'm
representing a brand i'm gonna be like
buddy don't do a space jam let's do
completely a different story you don't
need to do it that's mike
that's mj leave it alone you cannot beat
that guy's brand yeah but one warner
brothers
write you a check this big and it's like
hey can you make us relevant again but
here's the point anybody's willing to
write you check out that time you know
how many people want to write a check
for lebron like the story of don shito
like
wanting to get lebron there's hundreds
of people like that that are trying to
get lebron right now it's lebron
you got him to do any project you want
right now as long as you can cut the
check
he sounds like he's living quite the
life of privilege also why didn't they
cast his actual
family like his family in the movie
and if you're saying because those are
actors they could barely act
aren't you getting the actual family i
had to google it if those were his kids
i was like why does the lebron's kids
look like listen just because david
has a great voice he writes his own song
he plays the guitar he knows how to
woman woman it doesn't mean you can talk
trash with lebron
but that was a very good point by the
way thank you it was good
you're replaced kai get out david take
his place
all right so let's continue let's go to
disney let's go to disney let's go to
disney so disney
is moving 2000 jobs from california to
florida here's why
one of the great things about america's
50th state federal system is that people
can vote with their feet in response to
different policies the walt disney
company is the latest business to plan
to move some operations out of
california in favor of a lower
tax state disney will move two thousand
jobs from its california headquarters to
a new campus in florida
in a letter to employees disney
executive josh demaro explained that the
decision to relocate the jobs is partly
due to
florida's business friendly climate the
california policy center has documented
an extensive list of celebrities and
enterprises to leave the state due to
its high taxes and unfriendly business
climate this includes major corporations
like hule packard oracle palantir doll
food nestle toyota and many others
moving thousands of jobs out of
california
notable celebrities and entrepreneurs
including elon musk joe rogan ben
shapiro have left the state in recent
years as well thoughts
it's just like everything else you know
it's a slow trickle of negativity in
california and
when this all first started five six
seven years ago when the country started
to get divided i thought you know no way
this is the united states we're gonna
rally i i can't see this lasting forever
things are gonna turn but you know what
it's just like everything else a
celebrity here a company there
disney two thousand employees here and i
drive around la right now pat
you won't even recognize it for what it
was when you moved to the united states
or even right before you left
it's the deterioration of everything
it's ugly okay there's no pride in
keeping up the city anymore there is
graffiti everywhere
there's garbage everywhere underneath
every bridge
bridge overhang there's there's just
tons of trash now the winnebagos are
lined up and you know everybody is sick
of the homeless issue
it's just gotten so out of control um
for me i'm going to myself okay what is
going to be the tipping point for me
and here's what it is i've decided i
think i know what it is for me
it's if antifa comes starting to do what
they did in portland
if they turn la into their next
battleground i will run from that state
very very very fast and i'm a little
worried because they've already had
a few little battles and things going on
in la already but
you know this is just another example
and you can't get more powerful than
disney sending out a statement that says
florida is business friendly i mean
every single word in that statement was
calculated and they were sending that
missile
and they'll send more they'll send more
this is the first wave of them going out
there but you know they have a little
issue in orlando because there's no
housing
so if they send 2 000 people to orlando
there's very little inventory for houses
that's true
they don't have enough new homes they
don't have enough delivery 40 minutes
out 40 miles out
and by the way traffic in orlando is
getting bad it's not it's not like you
used to be 10 years ago
so that that's the other situation
they're dealing with but i mean look
that's a big deal 2 000 disney employees
moving to florida i really wouldn't
worry that much about it i think meet
kevin's going to organize the uh
national guard to come in and force
people to stay so there's that it's
gonna be uh
forced non-relocation but friendly
friendly look forward to your seven
corny uh response videos to that one gov
but the uh
but i gotta tell you man i am not very
happy about this because
these people are the parasites these
people are the parasite borg
from outer space who find they consume
all the resources in an area
and then they they suck it dry with
their progressive policies
and they come to a new area that's ripe
without them
and they're going to suck it dry as well
you think disney is not going to bring
their progressive policies to florida
you think they're not going to bring
their financial influence to the
political system
they already have them here they've got
a hundred thousand employees already
here two thousand
two thousand five thousand relocate the
headquarters
listen let me let me and they may and it
may happen right but you have to also
sit there and ask the question why are
we leaving why are we moving
right why are we leaving look i
i still remember gilbane hojet it's a
street i was born on
i still remember jam hospital it's the
hospital i was born in
i still remember gulbengian first five
years i went to gulbengian it was a
scarmedian school
i still remember the assyrian church i
used to go to i still remember
remember going to espond on vacation
with my family last the only vacation i
went on with my mom and dad i still
remember espen i still remember going to
bandar pal levy
and driving by rasht which now they've
changed the name to the city and we'd go
down and have caviar
i still remember tamusiq hushang these
are all friends and family i still
remember
every one of these guys it's still in my
blood i am from iran
i love the culture that we had during
that time
armenian assyrian from iran till today
it's in my heart
every single time we think about iran we
ask
why do we leave i couldn't say anything
i was silenced
we were afraid we were worried if you
told anybody you're christian if you
don't
and you would sit there like even as a
kid it didn't take a lot to realize
this concept didn't work freedom is
everything this is why we go to america
the greatest country in the world
till today i don't know what's going to
happen 10 years from now but till today
is the greatest country in the world
so a lot of these guys that are leaving
here's what i'm wondering
if you've ever read the book by bob iger
what's the book called kai the bob
biker's book is the
right of a lifetime right he talks about
how he's sitting with uh
murdoch i think he's in a book is he
sitting with murdoch and he's talking
about the fact murdock asks him so bob
any plans of running for office and
bob's like oh no i don't want to do
anything like that and he says in the
book i was thinking about it
but i couldn't tell him because what if
fox news goes out there and finds out
that i want to run what they would run
with it
i wanted to run and he wanted to run as
a what as a democrat
and governor wasn't he thinking right
away no no he wanted to go straight
to the presidency straight up to
presidency he's a democrat he talks
about why he's a democrat
he talked about why he's a democrat
because of his parents he's not a
democrat because he's a democrat he's a
democrat because he's loyal to his mom
and dad and it's a form of undermining
your family if you're a democrat right
i'd love to see some of these guys who
are democrats who are leaving california
and going to florida
not telling you to be a republican but
it's time to become an independent kind
of say hey
these policies you guys are representing
i just don't support anymore what the
hell is the matter with you
are you seeing that though there's
empirical evidence in both arizona and
texas that they don't they
they relocate because those those
policies failed
and then they vote for those same
policies in their new location but i
think
bob deep down inside is a logical guy i
think the only reason a person
wouldn't is pride ego of saying you were
right
it's the only reason but we all
eventually get to a point where we sit
there and we think there was an idea
that we thought was good we're
eventually going to question
it i think some of the guys are going to
start converting republicans don't help
either
especially with what happened with the
brand but but they don't they do not
help they don't open
they don't welcome people let's talk
about that let's talk about it i'm
actually curious to know what you're
going to say about this brandi love you
brought the story up to me yesterday i
don't know who brandy love is but
apparently bradley love is
uh one of your heroes just put me on
front street yeah
gerard uh uh very popular i can't grab
gerard's phone it's risky
if i grab one i have to be very careful
when i take gerard's phone
he snaps it out of my hands like if i
have this one in my head
so conservative porn star brandy love 48
is kicked out of florida's republican
conference for high school kids because
outraged parents complained daily mail
brandylla 48 attended the student action
summit with turning point usa in tampa
florida saturday and post for photos in
front of exhibits and a saving america
tour bus love initially arrived at tampa
convention center as an enthusiastic vip
guest but was
suddenly kicked out for backlash against
the christian organizers christian
conservatives immediately began
criticizing her attendance on social
media slamming her organization's
decision to allow an adult film star to
attend an event
targeted at 15 and 16 year olds she is
capitalizing on the
attention by selling t-shirts poking fun
at one of the conference's founders
she's selling shirts with the slogan i
trigger charlie kirk
on her only fan's website so what are
your thoughts about this dude this is
the reason i didn't grow up a republican
that what
one of the wild things over the course
of the last 15 20 years for anybody
that's been paying attention
to the political leanings of america has
been
watching when we were kids the christian
conservative of my youth was the karen
the christian conservative was the
person that was judgmental
telling you what you couldn't do they
were the the the arbit the
self-appointed arbiters of the zeitgeist
you can't do this we can't have that we
can't show these people holding hands on
tv
put the beds apart blah blah blah then
somewhere it shifted to this progressive
left became the woke left became the new
arbiters of the zeitgeist and what's
what's acceptable in a civilized society
and
and the ivy league kind of comes from
the ivy leagues when the ivy league
switch from william f buckley to
to uh you know aoc this this kind of
like this
was a legend they think they control
us and like what we can and can't think
and what we can and can't do and this
bothers me to no end
because it's exactly what you said if
i'm leaving
if i'm leaving my home because the
policies are so bad right there
i'm open-minded to a new idea and then
immediately i go and i and i come to a
new community this is a community event
and the first thing they say is you're
not good enough to be here you're not
perfect get out
i'm like screw these guys man absolutely
screw these guys
also if the idea is that the you know we
don't want to corrupt the minds of the
christian youth what was mary magdalene
dude what was mary magdalene's job
jesus himself took on who let me ask you
a question kai pull up swimsuit to
cover uh did you see the swimsuit
edition that just came out the sports
illustrated
did you see this that's the sports
uh annual swimsuit cover
transgender elena bloom wow okay
first transgender to be covered you
think that's okay
what do you think gerard i'm actually
curious
i think i don't stand a chance in miami
i gotta stop drinking boys
transgender that is unbelievable i would
never have guessed that in a million
years but i'm asking you gerard are you
okay with that
yeah i got no problem let people live
their life man what i don't like
specifically in the media is if if
they're promoting her
specifically because she's a transgender
i have an issue with that
i i want to live in a meritocracy as
much as possible okay
um but look she's beautiful
what i mean she's there's no way to say
she's not beautiful right i mean
we don't know how what photoshop is
doing there's no there's i don't know
man but
come on that's that's a swimsuit model
okay i mean it is what it is
so so for you this you're totally fine
with
i have no issue what do you think about
this i mean if you if you know the
sports illustrated swimsuit issue that's
what you get
so i'm not offended by it at all now
miss nevada i feel
bad for the naturally born women that
they lost
to a naturally born man who converted
mostly because i think
pull that story up i think what you're
doing is you're telling and
i just think that the image that you're
giving to young women is that you're not
good enough the way that you are
this other person got thousands of
dollars worth of surgery to make
themselves
the ideal candidate for miss nevada for
the
like like actually completely redid
their body
to be the perfect candidate for the
pageant system and i think that that's a
really
dangerous message so let me tell you
where i'm going with this gerard one day
when you have kids we'll talk and i'm
actually curious to know what position
you're gonna take so for me
i i understand and i responded to her
and i sent out a tweet i never got back
anything from her i don't think she
wanted to go that route and have that
conversation with me because
this is an event for 15 to 16 year olds
okay that's a targeted event for 15 to
16 year olds i don't care if you're a
porn star or anything
if it's 15 to 16 year olds it's not your
place to go
number one you're trying to create noise
which more power to you now if turning
point usa
is doing an event that's 24 year olds 30
year olds whatever and she goes and they
turn him down
now that's a different story right there
if you're losing that you're 15 16 year
old
do i uh am i okay with somebody going in
their where well just to be clear that's
how y'all forgive me but
was this a teen only event could you
only get tickets if you were
understanding if this story here is
saying 15 to 16 year olds i'm just
simply
sharing what this thing was a
conservative christian social media
slamming on the decision
targeted at 15 and 16 year olds but this
is but that doesn't mean exclusive too
if if it is what i'm saying to you is if
it is an event for teenagers
i can see why that concerned them if it
is if it is an event where that's the
teenagers i can see why parents
i can see why a parent may say i don't
want her to be there okay
like just like uh for me to say hey i'm
a uh
conservative drug dealer i'm just gonna
be here listen i'm trying to vote for
mega i'm on trump but i'm a conservative
drug
so if jay-z was there who
admitted a 20-year career selling crack
before he because he's doing it right
now
no so so her job precludes her ability
to
if it's right now yes why if jenna
jameson comes and you were doing it in
the past it's what i did in the past
it's a different story
what if she's not repentant about what
she did in her past like i mean that's
here here's the deal what do you mean by
that what if she's not repentant like
she said she does something she passed i
made a couple million dollars you're
forgiven totally fine but what but i'm
not asking for forgiveness i did my job
it's my job but there is but as a
parent i'm just giving you the optics of
the parent the parents going to be
worried about the fact that
here's a person around my kids that
could influence my kids to think
this is okay i don't want that i'm going
to be putting 80
pressure as parents are going to say hey
you guys got to make sure she's not here
because i don't want my kids to be
thinking about that okay so let me give
you some pushback on that if that's the
case if that's the way you personally
feel why wouldn't you retract
your kid from the situation why would
you infringe upon somebody else's rights
to be there if she wasn't doing anything
salacious
but but the target of the audience was
for teenagers the audience that was
being targeted for that is teenager so
i i don't know how to explain this for
from my perspective
i don't care if you're a former porn
star it does nothing to me
if that's what you chose to do with your
body more power to you if that's what
you chose what you to do with your body
but if you're going to a place publicity
stun to kind of drive more attention
with kids and teenagers in today's time
i don't know man i think it's a little
bit of a touchy subject on what you're
doing i i
you know the fact i'm with you the fact
that this was geared towards kids she
had no business being there because
a she's not known for her conservative
beliefs you're not hiring her
as a guest speaker or anything she is
there to sell porn and sell her image
and sell
sex and those kids are too
impressionable at that age there's no
reason for her to be there by the way
now let me give you a completely
different side of the
side of the story pamela anderson when
you think about it what do you think
about it baywatch
what else do you think you know just a
hot you know chick tommy
tommy you think about the time i got to
be honest i think a little more about
tommy lee a train wreck for 20 years
afterwards i was a kid when that thing
came out and i was like but
we got we got some growing watch what
happens as a human so you and baywatch
you went what a hot uh yeah just a
20-year train wreck and just
pop culture okay and then you said what
tommy lee right okay so now check this
out is she somebody
that you look at as an example for young
women and teenage boys
is that someone's like oh my gosh she
would be such a great no that's not the
first thing i would think about okay but
let me tell you how much of an example
she is on why i think she is
very necessary in today's society she
comes out and
she teaches her sons about porn and
here's what she says
she says listen she tells her sons i
would go
on dates with men and when it would come
down to having sex
these guys would start hitting me
slapping me doing all this stuff to me
like what are you doing this doesn't
feel good
so then i would say to my sons don't let
porn fool you
that's a movie that doesn't feel good
with everybody and not everybody
likes this you have to understand it so
she spoke to her sons about porn
and how to not get this misconception
about her porn is right okay
so is she fully qualified to share that
message with the people to see it
i think she's qualified qualified i
think she's very qualified she's an
authority on the matter
she is an absolute authority but guess
what i see with that i think that
if i'm putting an event together i don't
mind if that if somebody like that comes
and gives a message to young boys
yeah there's a there's a motive behind
it that's a positive motive
versus i go to this girl's twitter
account and i just kind of see what
she's doing brandy love
extremely attractive i'm sure there's a
big market for her
and then the next tweet is hey this is
the shower i'm going to be showering out
of today
and here's the view so to me if it was
exclusive to
i i don't know enough about it i don't
either i'm telling you right now it's
exclusive to kids and she
got it under false pretense i i'll i'll
back off for sure
but if it was open to the public and
they were just marketing it to younger
kids if it was like a disney thing where
it's open to everybody but we're
marketing
but still that's just as bad because
because
if you're marketing it to kids then
you're bringing in a whole generation of
kids that should not be exposed to porn
at that point
that they are should not be allowed by
the way by the way i put that on turning
point usa and let me tell you why
you tell me a club like back in the days
there was a club called carnival
in l.a carnival was 14 and up you
shouldn't have a club that's 14 and up
so by the way let me say that one more
escape it was 12. we had a club that was
14 and up yeah
are you out of your flipping minds my
father would never
ever ever ever ever let us go to this
club i was 16 years old
cabaret 12 year old who how did this
pass the zone here's the how do you
bring that to the board here's a point
though you're 16 year old years old you
go there yeah well
who's the market and i'm 16 i'm tall so
i don't look 16. i probably look 22.
i mean i've looked 40 since i was 16
anyway so it's not like it takes years
so you go there next thing you know and
by the way okay carnival this club you
know what it had
it had you know how you have the booth
with the couch and all that stuff
they had rope they had what do you call
it drapes to cover it up oh
fantastic without pay you didn't have to
there was a bottle service right yeah
i'm playing 15 16 years old i'm going
over here and
you're like okay yeah so so the point is
that's where you learn some of your game
and you know it right that's
your crap that's like you know how long
that club lasted
not a long time sponsored by wayfair
meaning the point is turning point usa
has to learn from this to know if you're
saying
under 18 you have to keep it under i
need to know what's what else though
like i mean would you have an issue with
jay-z being there
no i would you know sylvester stallone
started look porn is dangerous and you
do not expose that to 15 or 16. so
stallone started in porn would you have
a problem with him come on nobody knows
that
nobody knows
is that she is right now at this moment
a porn star
damn right what if somebody was uh was a
weed entrepreneur should they be
should be there should not should not be
there no this even if it's illegal
yeah i'm telling you he should not be
there what do you think of sex ed in
schools um
who i don't trust teachers teaching
anything these days so i don't know i
mean
our kids are doing sex ed through a
little private thing that we have in the
in the school also
which i stay very very clear of i want
nothing to do with those meetings by the
way you know what i'm dealing with so we
get into town yesterday with the kids
right dash and ivana are here and
just going to dash dash which you got
going to you know i might be heading out
on a boat
so apparently one of his friends from
california
who's famous i'll tell you who it is
later but apparently he's in town too
and i gotta hold him and said they might
be taking him out on a yacht
he's 12 years old and he goes i might be
heading out on a boat today
really okay well let us know how that
goes
have fun in central pain shonda was at
the house a couple days ago
and she's by the way she's freaking what
she's doing is amazing
i told that's ashanda if you ever move
to florida ever i'm going to be your
agent you can sell yachts you can sell
whatever you want to do she'll crush it
when it comes on to doing all this
interior designing stuff with the house
she knows what she's doing
but she shows picture of dash i said
caroline i want you to look a picture of
dash
so she pulls pictures of dash and we
pull i pull young pictures of brad pitt
it's as if they're twins no joke his son
looks just like brad pitt yeah i've seen
his wife
yeah so yeah yeah so
look i don't know not that tom's not a
good looking guy you're very attractive
yourself
i i don't know about this story here
quite frankly it's a bit annoying when
you think about the story here one
interesting statistic by the way 93 000
people died of drug over overdoses
in us during the pandemic in 2020
staggering loss of human life let me say
that one more time
93 000 people died of drug overdose okay
so now the question i asked immediately
was
how many was the highest a year prior to
that right over those
that death sort of 93 000 the mess of
covenant penalty us government reported
wednesday the provisional estimated by
cdc
for eclipses the high of about 72 000
drug overdoses
uh a year ago reached the previous year
and amounts to 29
increased lockdowns and other pandemic
restrictions isolated those with drug
addictions that made treatment
harder to get experts said overdose
death deaths are
just one facet of what uh was overall
the deadliest year
in u.s history with about 378 thousand
that's attributed over 19 with national
saw
the nation saw more than 3.3 million uh
debts
uh the estimate of 93 000 over the
overdoses uh
translates to an average of more than
250 deaths a day
roughly 11 each hour so 21
000 more than average last year what
does that tell you about isolation
not good not good at all and those are
just the numbers that are reported that
can be directly
you know attributed to it what about the
the slow burn that you have the cancers
or some of the other things that come
from the drug it's an epidemic it's so
horrible
and the most disgusting thing when you
think about this is
big pharma knows a lot about this thing
when you think about the opioids and
when you think
when you think they know they make
prozac right an antidepressant and they
know there will be a certain of
percentage of people that will become
homicidal and suicidal and they do not
give a damn yeah i call it acceptable
risk
yeah and you know luckily the purdue
family is starting to pay i mean these
are evil people if you create these
drugs
that you know are going to get people
addicted and what you do
which it's him i mean everybody knows
somebody everybody's seen it you know
you have a little back injury you start
on
oxycontin and you can't get off it and
it gets worse and worse and worse i mean
these drug companies are despicable i
didn't think we were going to cover this
one because
now you're going to get one of my little
rants here but dude this is like again
like my god almighty the first thing
that we did
is we shut down the the schools we shut
down the churches
we kept the liquor stores open we shut
down the gyms we kept the freaking uh we
shut down outdoors outdoors people
couldn't go in the beach they couldn't
walk in the
in the sand they couldn't dip themselves
in the water you couldn't go into a pool
you could do nothing nothing for your
mental health
nothing all you could do was sit there
bored and anxious and get drunk that's
all
that's all i did for a year watching my
money go away
less and less and less watching my
credit score drop having all the anxiety
of people in your life thinking like
that that they're buying into this media
[ __ ]
no matter what numbers i'm trying to
show them the the amount of stress i had
the amount of stress everybody had
you're losing your job you don't know
what's going to happen there's a damn
coup going on in in the government
and all they give you is nothing but
booze and they sit here and they say
wear your mask wear your mask if it
saves one life
if it saves what life wear mask over
your eyes too
these freaking people and then the first
thing biden does what he gets his office
is he bombs people
we sat there for a year if it saves his
one life and the first thing he does he
gives
raytheon a quarter billion dollars to
drop bombs on people in syria but i was
saying just one life you know how many
people we killed with this [ __ ] man
and we're still going through at this
kabuki theater they're making people put
masks back on now
it drives me out of my mind that we're
even entertaining this
anybody who looks at what happened over
the last 18 months
i'm talking the democrat politicians
that did it the democrat voters that
supported it
and the rest of us that allowed it to
happen
if we all don't look at what happened
and just feel an immense amount of shame
just shame that we allowed this to
happen to ourselves our freedoms and our
neighbors
anybody who doesn't feel that shame
they're either a [ __ ]
or a sociopath and any one of them can
screw off
your opinions from here on out our void
i don't want to hear you i don't care i
don't care if you don't like me
you're a [ __ ] and i don't want to hear
your opinion you've lost
any benefit of the doubt i would say i
would say
you know uh on the on the people who
allowed this to happen what what market
research did they have to look at to see
if any of this stuff was real or not
like what can they look at
you know you're you're the 80 the
majority let's just say folks who
just vote just to vote they don't vote
because they do a lot of research on
politics what the hell do they know
about pandemics what do they know about
a virus oh they're sitting there saying
i don't want to lose my husband i don't
want to lose my wife i don't want to
lose my mom i don't want to lose my dad
i don't put it on the people uh i say
you know the power of affirmations man
years ago
i grew up in an environment gerard that
for me
it was you can't do anything we're not
special people
just try to do whatever you can to
survive there's no way
you know we're meant to do anything
special with our lives all the
affirmations weren't strong middle
eastern culture is not a lift up type of
an environment
but affirmations one day a guy tells me
try this
so what do i do i go get laminate my
affirmations and i put it all over the
place in my shower wall
in my mirror in my car in my wallet in
my backpack in my
computer i put it everywhere and my
padfolio it was
everyone i read it nonstop eventually i
took my affirmations and i
recorded with a sound and i just
listened to it was five minutes on my
drive every morning i would listen to it
you know
be careful what you joke about or be
sarcastic about because your spirit's
going to have sp
will stop having faith in wars that come
out of your mouth you know i have met
the enemy it is i alexander
i would read these 30 every day every
day
5 10 15 times a day until i started
believing it
when i believed it my confidence like
dude it's over
did you actually take a video on this is
one of your better videos but the point
i'm trying to make to you is
this is not the folks who fell for it
the ultimate affirmation the last 18
months
is the media gerard i agree and i
disagree and this is why
i agree with you up into a point but
when you had
800 000 people at some transgender
uh rights uh protest in brooklyn
in the middle of of in the middle of the
pandemic
800 000 people shoulder to shoulder and
that was okay
that was okay when you had the
scientists the quote unquote trust the
science
coming out and saying these massive
protests
are okay because racism is a pandemic
too it's one or the other
either you can have a million people
marching in the streets
or you i can open my business and then
the fact that we
didn't do it it's on us ultimately yeah
we did many of us did a lot of stuff
about it
you make it seem like nobody did it
maybe you did it down in florida i'm
telling you right now new york new
jersey the businesses they closed well
guess what they're going to pay price
for it and good for them
they're going to pay a price for it you
don't think new york's paying a price
for it right now dude everybody i'm
talking to right now
everybody i'm talking to right now in
new york where in florida where are you
from new york where are you from jersey
where are you from dc where are you from
new york where everybody sure yeah i
don't know everybody
you don't think california is going to
pay per price for you don't think
portland oregon is going to pay a price
for it
you don't think illinois is going to pay
maps what you're saying instead of push
back we just left
no you can't do anything with pushback
listen you're very helpless
you cannot do anything when you're going
up against folks in the government
you cannot do anything with it at that
time no matter how much your vote
matters when they say your vote matters
okay so go back to the whole thing with
what's going on with cuba mexico right
now
go back to it so why is biden's camp
saying no we're not going to let anybody
come here with boats
oh but mexicans want to cross the border
anybody want to across the board
why is one okay and the other one's not
okay they think mexicans vote democrat
and cubans vote republican
democrats are cubans are escaping a
unbroken system and philosophy that
didn't work they're coming to america to
see how great america is gen saki won't
even
won't even say the word communism you
won't even say it yeah but
what i think what i think is you know
elections have
consequences you've heard this a million
times when they have consequences
i think what just happened recently two
events one is a new york mets game that
you brought it up
can you pull up this video please yeah
what's the new york mets game and i want
to show this to you and the other one is
uh john kerry refusing to wear a mask
even though he makes everybody in the
world wear one
here's what happens at a new york mets
uh starting from the beginning
and make it bigger kai nets and yankees
by the way
go all the way to the back watch this so
mets and yankees this one guy
the security is asking him to take off
the mega hat is what the security is
asking him to do
and then watch what this other not
caucasian
guy is telling them to do with the hat
watch this well the whole crowd really
[Music]
[Applause]
watch
[Music]
put the hat back on bro put it on put it
[Applause]
on
put it on
new yorkers have so much charisma you
know there's other videos too if you
scroll down
you'll see a wider shot of it where the
whole section is going nuts the whole
stadium is actually cheering for it
it's not magga doesn't mean donald trump
anymore it means anti this establishment
is what it's turning into it doesn't
mean i mean that those were clearly
white supremacists obviously so i mean
it's that's a focus group right there go
go to
go to the other video with me there's
such a disconnect between
the world our media tells us
well yeah well anyways megan fox you
know okay uh
follow up to gerard durant it's coming
back
sorry about the ramp no no it was good
but what do we do now because
they are going to do it again watch
watch your media reports
everything is now about the delta
variant the numbers it's coming
they're starting to make you wear mass
inside again whether you've been
vaccinated or not
it is it's they're going to follow the
exact same playbook
and they're going to rip it and here's
the other thing too they're going to use
the olympics as their biggest psa
for coronavirus it's going to make its
coming out party part
due because there's not gonna be any
fans there you know and then
look you got these basketball players
one is tested positive i think bradley
beal
right and then you got uh other guys
that are in in quarantine right now
now the gymnastics team all right that
is nbc's bread and butter
i mean everybody wants to watch the
simone biles you know the whole thing
but now the alternate has tested
positive and she's been around her
for a long time and and you know what
the usa today the la times the
uh new york they could not be happier
they could not be more gideon the
saddest thing about this is that there's
a 50 50 chance this entire interview
gets taken down now
we just did this with with beasley we
went we did a hundred thousand views in
an hour cole beasley
and see you later steve reich so
i mean you got to stop saying that
though buddy because i don't i don't i
don't want uh
people to think that this is a channel
that we do that because i don't i don't
stand for that i know you don't i
and what i mean by that is but even
saying it we don't even need to say it
so whether they do or not
we are gonna do our part and we're gonna
talk there is not a one-sided
story here we're all sharing our message
right now if the populist agrees with
the disagrees with the let them have the
discourse there's nobody here that's
given such a one-sided story where all
of us are
a hundred percent on that we're
encouraging people to not go do a
decision that's going to jeopardize
their lives that's not what we're saying
all you're saying is my interpretation
of what you said
is question what the hell is going on
and stop being knight that's how i
interpreted what you said
you're a man with passion you're a man
that's red your entire you got very
strong opinions you come from an
infrastructure with your family which
most people don't know they're
strong democrats with strong lineage to
a university but your family's still
together your sisters love you
you're a guy that off camera is a great
guy so if youtube wants to do that
that's on them but i disagree i think we
are
in a very we're coming from a place that
we're allowing the audience to make a
decision for themselves and if they like
it great they don't like it great
by the way we're at 68 000 subs right
now we get to 100 000 subs you asked me
yesterday i'd like to go to three times
a week but i'm not going to do it until
we get 100 000 subs it just doesn't make
sense for me to do it right now
if the audience wants more of this we'll
do it if they don't we'll shut the
channel down
i don't wake up in the morning with the
idea of wanting to do this message
because i need more attention in my life
god knows
i'm at the office yesterday you know
what time i left the office last night i
am dude one day
in the morning i didn't get house till 1
45 i didn't go wake up and sleep on my
bed last night i slept on a damn couch
last night because i didn't want to wake
up my kid or my wife
and i'm back at the office this morning
we're not doing this because i need
another million dollars in a damn bank
account
i'm doing this because i freaking love
this country and we're going to talk
about it people see it they want more of
it great supported you don't don't
i'm okay i i trust the fact that the
human people are eventually going to be
able to make
question themselves put put the brian
stelter thing went on cnn kai can you
put that up real quick
i mean you have to realize here's an
author
who goes on cnn to sell his books
who's not necessarily a trump guy at all
this is not a he hates trump
and he the channel that he's supposed to
defend go to the last two minutes go
from uh
no go from uh go back go back 40 seconds
go
from uh 240 go from 240.
play this i think it's important to
mention also you know as long as i've
known you
you never wanted to be political you
never wanted to know i didn't want to
touch this but
but to me freedom is that important
i told you this last time when we were
talking when we're over here i said
people are going to show up from the
word works
because i believe if your message is the
right message i believe the right people
will show up
listen when we started our company
insurance company we had 66 agents i'm
not i've never once sold insurance to
any of my following and i've never once
pitched my company to anybody i don't do
it you've never
have i ever tried to sell you an
insurance policy no have i ever tried to
sell you an insurance plan i don't know
if you have a license
yeah i've never i've never
even done that to people around me right
but i'm gonna tell you what happened
a couple times certain events happen
that i can't take credit for
there are certain things that happen i'm
like there's no way in the world i get
credit for this no way in the world i
get credit for this
and you have uh uh eventually certain
things started happening i'm like listen
either the power out there whether it's
god
energy whatever you want either somebody
wants this to become a reality or they
don't i'm not gonna fight it if you
don't want it to become a reality
i'm just gonna put my effort the message
that we have
is getting millions of eyeballs if
people want it they're going to show up
what's crazy is some of the people that
have showed you dms where i showed you
these are
well-known celebrities that can't
publicly talk about it well-known
athletes that cannot publicly talk about
it
but they listen to our podcast and they
agree with what we're talking about yeah
and they're saying it's so necessary
today
what is the tipping point a year two
years five years ten years i don't know
but we're gonna do our part so
kai pull up this video real quick for us
to see here's a guy
michael wolff that's selling his book
landslide the final days of the trump
presidency
does that sound like a title that says
good things about trump by the way all
right
now watch how he torches cnn
go ahead is that how it works that's how
you get it
but yeah but i don't yeah but i don't
want you to think that
that that what i said at that point was
in any way
inauthentic i think the media has done a
terrible job on this
i think you yourself um you know
why you're a nice guy you know you're
full of sanctimony
um you know you become part of one of
the parts of the problem of the media
you know you come on here and you and
you have a um
you know a monopoly on truth you know
you know exactly how things are supposed
to be done
um you know you are why one of the
reasons people can't understand the
meaning
turns out
that's all he can do
so what should i do differently michael
ask listen you know don't talk so much
listen more
you know people have genuine problems
with with with the media the media
doesn't get the story right
the media exists in its own bubble
um that's true i agree you uh
um you know you gotta stop i mean that
last segment that
that that i just had to listen to people
saying the same old stuff
also you're incredibly repetitive it's
week after week i mean
you're the flip side of of of donald
trump
um you know fake news and you say
virtuous news
you know i they're they're not just
figure out what is real i mean
well figuring out yeah figuring out what
is real is not so
is not so uh it's not so easy and and
you know most people don't want to talk
turn to brian stelter to tell us what's
real
i'm sorry well then why'd you bother
coming on cnn a few times this week
watch his answer
very honest you know
i'm uh i'm i'm a book salesman
capitalism obviously right i'm grateful
you came on watch this i'll see you for
yourself
and i guess let's do it again in four
years thanks so much
see ya you know that was an intellectual
mismatch right there
he had you could just see the wheel
spinning he's never they're never
challenged
they don't even know what to do when
someone doesn't it's not an echo chamber
for them so i freaked out
bezos is adam and eve rocket we talked
about pam anderson brandy love
we i we looked at megan fox looking
better than she's ever looked in her
life
and that right there was the sexiest
thing i've seen all day
you're kidding me you know what and you
know what that is that here's what that
is
there is nothing like your own kid
coming to you telling you you're wrong
nothing it's very painful and you know
they're right there's nothing like
somebody from your own side coming to
you and telling you you're wrong and
that's exactly what they're experiencing
right now and he's going to sell a heck
of a lot more books because i think
people from either side are going to
want to like hear
more from this guy you know it's how
much longer can they
keep it up man the media you know pat we
talked about it yesterday man like what
kills me about this moment is like we
are quantifiably
the most successful humans to ever live
true they're we are the most literal
we are the most educated we have the
most access to nutrients we are living
longer
we are living better the average person
today the middle class person today
lives a life in excess of 18th century
uh oligarchs like we have access to like
climate control
you're never in a room that's too hot
you're never in a room that's too cold
you never have a belly that that that's
empty you know you don't like
and yet all we hear every single day and
this is an american thing i'm not
talking about across the world all we
hear
is how bad everything is yeah and
because things aren't perfect this the
marxists are selling
our kids specifically that things aren't
perfect
so blow it up you guys grew up in a
world
not even 30 years ago i was a kid there
was actual apartheid
they want to tell us that things are
worse than they've ever been there was
apartheid in the 80s man
ireland and and ireland and britain were
blowing each other
up in the mid 90s clinton is the one who
who did the uh the the belfast agreement
like that you would literally have
terrorist attacks on the reg
and i'm not i'm not talking about you
know like we talked about in in war
ravaged
you know middle eastern countries that
have basically been a proxy for wars
between
united states and china united states
and russia we're talking about
britain you know what i mean like we are
living in in the pax americana man when
historians look back at this time
they're going to be like
man these guys were really angsty and
angry over what they were killing it
like like
everybody should have been partying but
that's exactly why when i told you
affirmations have power and what i mean
to you with
you know media this just validated it
when you say the same thing a million
times
if hitler used to say if you tell a lie
enough times you eventually end up
believing it the big lie that is their
philosophy say it over and over there is
so much positive and negative power in
affirmations but what we have to do that
man
showed incredible courage yeah an
incredible religion yes and it's on
us in the public in the zeitgeist to
support that he will be supporting
and he will be supporting he's a
reflection of what's going on right now
because i just believe
people are on to it and people are most
people are blessed with some common
sense and then the other thing that this
country is just lacking and which is
just pathetic is toughness
i mean everybody the the the level of
offense over everything is making us an
incredibly weak country
if things aren't perfect it's horrible
that's why i don't even like talking
negatively about
um social media or big tech because my
my life is way better with google in it
you know can you i mean remember back
when we drove and we didn't have gps
i don't even know how we did it how did
we find addresses
that's a very good question you know and
apple makes our life stronger
you fight your wife why did you say left
it's the next one make a right
i honest we were younger not as smart as
we are now we still upside
in big cities i do not know how we did
it and you know what i i put a little
i'll put something over my camera on my
computer if someone's listening or
watching
i will take the convenience and i just
think as a country we have to have a
little bit more gratitude and be a
little bit more grateful for the times
that we're looking at maps
if we had to go back to all to manual
transmission i would go nowhere
you don't miss it i miss it really oh my
gosh there was something about manual
transmission
no you you know total control number one
you know you
and if you like speed you have the
ability to get going a lot more i
learned how to drive on one of the left
foot with a lot
dude that's such a magics like music
manual transmissions like music it's
like all the melodies have to hit at the
right time for it to go and you know
it's
yeah you know somebody know how to drive
manual when it's uphill
and it's red light oh my god you would
wait you're like
you're stopping
[Music]
how many employees between php and v and
valuetainment do you have
15 000. how many do you think can drive
manual transmission right now that's a
good question i would probably say
uh 10 to 15 percent do you think that
yeah because i think it's the age 35 if
you're 35 you know how to drive manual
if if you're if you're 20 you don't but
if you're 35 you know how to drive do
you know how to drive manual or no man
theoretically
david can you try that i was taught on
manual my dad said you'll learn manual
and then you can drive any car can you
drive manual or no
no i cannot but i've been wanting to
okay there you go she has interest all
right
all right so let me let me read this
next bucket list let me let me read this
next story which is a little creepy
folks
brace for impact this is not fake news
this is a real story democrats want to
monitor your text
and use aggressive fact checkers to
dispel vaccine misinformation reports
claims this is the daily mail story the
biden administration is planning to ramp
up efforts to combat vaccine
uh misinformation in areas where
vaccination rates are lagging and
coveted cases are rising according to
reports
the dnc is considering working with sms
companies to vet
texts texts and send messages directly
to americans to stop the spread of
inaccurate information the party
organization is also reportedly
considering employing aggressive fact
checkers
to monitor communication in a planning
of drawn furious pushback from
conservatives
the biden administration officials are
now looking at the next step as 91
million people remain unvaccinated and
43 states are seeing an increase in
covet infections
in the last week as data variants delta
variance causes
cases to spike
aggressive fact checkers i mean could
there be a more scary phrase out there
i mean i don't know it's it's one of
those stories that seems made up i have
some notes i'm going to find them here
in one second
you know i thought i spent four years
being told by every liberal that i know
that donald trump was this outrageous
dictator yet
they absolutely have lost their voice
when it comes to joe biden wanting to
read or text our emails and sending
people door to door
to stab us with some mixed some mystery
juice i i i don't
uh i i'd love for them to find their
their uh their fear of of autocratic
tyranny again i you know this this idea
that we were living
on on the brink of fascism but you know
they're reading your texts for your own
good don't worry about it these people
are nuts men you know who's driving this
because if joe biden was president say
when clinton was president
if he became president in 1992 he
wouldn't be doing this stuff right i
don't think i don't
know how many original thoughts joe
biden has right now
any real vision where is it coming from
yeah is is there a group
is there one person is it two is it five
is it the radicals is it
i don't know man i i don't know you know
but the the way that they just
outright lie also now with no
consequence
you know i said it the last time i was
on the podcast but i
i only can hear every time i hear jen
sackey talk
i just hear alexander slosnich from the
the gulag archipelago
we know that they're lying they know
that we know that they're lying we know
that they know
that we know that they're lying and yet
they still lie she says on one day
we we're telling facebook we are helping
facebook flag
uh dangerously misinformed posts
and then the next day she goes we're not
having any posts taken down what are you
talking about
where'd you get that information two
days back to back she made those claims
and it's like
my god what what this is coming from the
white house
the white house is saying we're working
with a private company to
censor information that we don't like
and then the next day she just flat out
denies that they're doing it
to the press and the press don't push
her on it i don't understand what's
happening
by the way politico wrote this article
originally
usa today responded saying the fact that
this is not a true story but they're not
saying that it's not
a true story they're saying it's uh uh
fact check biden doesn't want to monitor
private text for vaccine
uh misinformation this is a usa today's
story biden wants phone companies to
monitor the people text for vaccination
the claim
and they're answering it that it's not
now i'm going to put the story below
if you can pull this story up already
based on the recent claim by informing
one comes to monitor people's
vaccines so usa today type in usa today
sms text go to it and i'll
read the story at the end uh
text biden just put sms text biden and
let me see if it comes of actually okay
the go go to that one and go all the way
to the bottom let's read it together
can you make the screen bigger so the
audience can see this rather than seeing
us
okay so if you go to the story all the
way in the bottom keep going keep going
keep going okay a little bit higher a
little bit higher right there
okay you know a little higher a little
higher okay our ratings falls
our rating falls based on our research
the clinton bidet wants phone companies
monitor people's textbooks i'm using
false this is a misinterpretation of a
kai what are you doing kai
this is a mystery this is a
misinterpretation of people of
kai just stop doing what you're doing
buddy oh my gosh don't touch the
computer
this is a misinterpretation of dnc's
effort to report this information
a spokesperson from the dnc said it has
no ability to monitor private text
messages and said that the nccr's
instance is a possible term of use of
violation reported by the public
to the sms api companies the biden
administration is not involved
i don't know how that means fact by the
way go a little higher to read the
dates uh what does that say on the
bottom no the other way the other way go
uh okay got it so i look i don't know if
it's saying
if it's not or it is so basically trust
me bro
yeah that's exactly what that sounded
like that's what that sounded it's a
trial balloon how much outrage is there
going to be because if it's not too big
then we'll actually do it
here's a question for you guys here's a
question for you what's such a big deal
what's such a big deal if they check
your text huh hear me out
they're if they're already you don't
think they're checking stuff on social
you don't think they're checking stuff
on facebook
on twitter you don't think they're
checking stuff on youtube what's next
next is text why are you surprised
if they're trying to impose to do that
why are you surprised i'm not saying
support it and do it but why are you
surprised that they would try to reach
to go to text
just because it's a one-on-one
communication and you would anticipate
it be a little bit more private
there's one thing that you publish and
there's then another thing that that's
private imagine if like
every draft your first draft went public
you know what i'm saying like that's you
there's what you put out into the world
i'm not surprised though i'm not saying
you should be surprised it doesn't make
it doesn't make it right
i never said it i never said it make
sure we should push back on things that
are wrong shouldn't we have a hundred
percent 100 100 but i'm not surprised
that they're trying to go there next
do you have do you have fear or anxiety
at all
about the you know how they're starting
to say the loud the quiet parts out loud
how the surveillance you know state is
basically being exposed and that
you know we are we are a proxy to our
you whether whether you want to believe
it's the nsa the cia
the uh the homeland security i mean
they're really running the ship here you
really believe they're not tracking
stuff
of course they are so but now they're
doing it publicly no no i get that you
really believe that they're saying we're
not doing that
snowden talked about this how many years
ago yeah so
you don't think that certain words are
being followed like we have an sms
system right that we send messages at
we have the ability to have you text a
word
that sends a any report back to you a
pdf back to you it's automated
and we send a pdf back to you you don't
think they have the technology to look
at 20 key words
to see what that conversation sounds
like the patriot act is such an
abomination
it stands against everything about it
with giuliani it's it's an abomination
and he he was a proponent of it and now
he's a critic of it
it's it's no fun when the rabbit's got
it right but if you're
if you're well right now you're an
american citizen you're
maybe the most pro-american guy i've
ever met if you have a third cousin
in iran or from or or in syria
and they're doing something nefarious
somebody that you've never met in your
life
you are now exposed to the fisa courts
they can they can tap you they can have
warrantless wiretaps on you because
you're two steps away from from a target
that's that's
asinine man we have to have some
semblance of privacy and privacy is
freedom right like we can't
we can't just allow these guys to be in
our lives at all times especially if
it's ai flagging us
right can we i mean am i the only guy
no i'm with you a hundred percent we're
on the same yeah i have a question for
you guys if i may so earlier we spoke
please don't
please don't raise your voice just to
have more power over us
lower your audio 10 instead of screaming
at us the way you just did like
go ahead voice of god so uh so we spoke
about how important
by the way why don't you do the first
three lines of your song go ahead and do
it okay no
do the first three can't do it right do
two of them no right now
i need the guitar go grab it no no no
you're not gonna ask the question if
you're gonna do that go get the guitar
for him kyle you go do that
he's gonna do it live three times i got
20 minutes no no no go grab
i'm telling you go grab the guitar we'll
do it for the next no no we're not doing
that go grab the guitar
go grab the guitar and then you can ask
your question well i want to know your
questions i forgot about that we're not
working
this environment is a pressure type of
environment go get it all right let's go
ahead and erase my voice and now no no
no no
can you see this getting pulled back at
all or are we too far to the edge
do you see the world ever are we just
gonna have to become
cognizant of no we're not it's not going
to be people we're not wired that way
look
we are wired to be able to sin
and choose not to sin we are not
wired to be robots none of us we are
wired to make mistakes
whenever in a relationship in a
parent relationship in a marriage in a
friendship in a work environment
it gets to the point where you're
walking on eggshells
it creates such an environment of
anxiety and panic
that people start doing crazy stuff you
cannot do that long term it is not a
sustainable model
history has proven when you do this for
too long people eventually snap
and it's not a pretty snap when they do
so it's not going to be a pretty thing
for them long term you cannot
you cannot mess with this part i have to
have the freedom to sin
my kids if i tell them don't do it
here's how my daughter is okay
i'll say i'm not even kidding with you
here's the wiring
i'll say sena don't touch
the what do you call it the uh the
remote control no no the
the whatever it's not slinky the slimy
stuff
i'm like senna put the slime ball down
she goes like this
she just has to do it so
i'll tell you stop kicking your brother
he has to do it one more time he just
kicks them one more time
dylan stop hitting my back he just taps
it one more time
i mean he would like that yeah that's
just like you know so what are you gonna
do if you tell them don't do that i mean
they're gonna do it so
we don't change from being kids so the
game plan for me is the following
i'm going to treat you so good i'm going
to be respectful to you i'm going to
bring value to you
that you want me in your life i'm going
to treat you so well that you won't you
want to stay my client for a long time
i'm going to take care of you that you
want to stay with me as an audience i
want to be
that's the only way when you do it this
way history doesn't favor people like
this
yep plenty of examples by the way this
does not mean america cannot lose
everything it has i didn't say that
i never said that this let me let me
straighten that part out this doesn't
mean america cannot lose
all its freedom it has this doesn't mean
that
this only means that if america does
another america is going to pop up
that's what this means
i interviewed the guy from 2034. what is
him elliot akerman i think his name is
elliot ackerman the guy's got a purple
heart silver
he's got everything right he said
history tells us
that empires tend to self-destruct at
years are we at right now oh god where
are we at right now
you know what we're 49 yeah no just do
the math 1776 plus 250 45 240. there you
go
give or take so 1776
is what plus uh uh what what is that 244
245 245 we got five more years to go
self-destruct he says that
empires at 250 self-destruct we're still
a baby
we still can't self-destruct but the
ideas that america was founded on were
ideas that
rome was founded on was ideas that
assyria was founded on was ideas that
many empires were founded on and then
there's money wealth bureaucrats
aristocrats show up they spend the money
they do stupid [ __ ]
then people take those ideas to a new
country and they started all over again
that's going to happen
freedom seems to be temporary throughout
history right
because it eventually attracts power
tripping
people that think that think they are
smarter than you and they want to impose
their power control and thoughts over
you and people take it for granted
the third generation yeah away from
we're three generations away from world
war ii now right
so people just think that this way that
they grew up is the way it's always been
it's like the people that are
working away from home or from away from
the office i think that
that's the new normal that it should be
i mean that is just so illogical
look all i can say to you is there's a
reason why people are going to space
okay this just don't all make sense
space just cleaning it up and uh you
know going through stuff anyways so
let's go to the next store you want to
do megan fox you want to do bill burr
what story do you want you tell me what
story
okay let's do anti-sex bets in the
olympic village a social media theory
is soon debunked okay page five if you
want to go to this
so kai you want to pull up that video
where the kid jumps on the bed
so anti-sex beds in the olympic villages
social media theory is soon debunked the
new york times competitors arriving at
the tokyo olympics have discovered
something unusual about the beds and the
athletes village they're made out of
cardboard
organizers say it's the first time that
the beds at the games will be made
almost entirely out of renewable
materials but in the time
of the coronavirus when olympic
organizers worried about transmissions
are trying to discourage close contact
as much as possible the unusual bed
frames have led
some to suggest there's another motive
behind them paul chellimo kalimo an
american distance runners speculated on
twitter that the beds were
unable to support more than one person
and were aimed to uh at avoiding
intimacy amongst athletes
soon the beds were being labeled on
social media as anti-sex
ryan mcclengan a gymnast from ireland
called to claim fake news a video he
posted on twitter showed him jumping on
top of his bed demonstrated that it
could only withstand it could withstand
vigorous activity the official olympics
twitter account reposted his video
adding thanks for de-punking the punking
debunking the myth here's a video
in today's episode of fake news at the
olympic games
the beds are meant to be anti-sex
they're made out of cardboard yes
but apparently they're meant to break at
any sudden movements
it's fake fake news news
he's a gymnast he only weighs 15 pounds
i mean come on
by the way is brandy love an alternate
on any of the olympic teams she might
just show up out there
you know like these guys wouldn't be
able to figure out to throw that
mattress on the ground
right but you know sex is such a big
deal at the olympics they hand out
condoms right you know that's always a
big story
160 000 they've handed out in japan and
the record is what 450 000 that they did
in rio it would be interesting to find
out what really does go on in those
olympic villages
i mean that's a lot of condoms what are
you saying i'm saying
like there's a lot of sex that goes on
you know you're saying like if somebody
if an olympic athlete had an only fan's
chance
showing in their bedroom like they would
get millions of people that would
buy is that kind of are you saying the
business model i'm saying it would be
fascinating to learn i mean they got a
lot of downtime they're all athletic a
lot of hormones
they're all a lot of them are very very
attractive i mean you can see it makes
sense but you just
you don't associate that with the
olympics but it's clearly going on
in a very very big way it's a lot of
condoms
i i'd look at that and i would say
challenge accepted boy
let's let's let's bust some boxes baby
you know imagine the sumo wrestlers they
got to sleep on some cardboard out there
bro
i look at that and i'm like man forget
sex that doesn't have the structural
integrity for my lumbar man like
first of all who's still having sex on
beds this is 20 20 grow up people
like you know you gotta find some some
exciting things to do here so you're
saying it's fake news you're gonna
you're gonna find them on the counter
it wasn't me you saw me on the sofa i
think it totally makes sense
there would be a way for them to try to
take any sort of fun and enjoyment out
of life and
i can see the initial reaction is that's
what they were doing but but it's
it there's gravity they'll be all right
yeah
you're going to stop yeah so you're not
buying it you're going to stop no i
don't think it's an answer
athletic 25 years and it certainly
wouldn't stop anybody because you just
take it right off the bed you throw the
mattress on the ground uh-huh
is that what you would do yes i'm an
olympic uh i have a
trained mind like an olympian you know
look i mean
where there's a will there's a way right
i mean you know we could we could
problem solve this thing together
this is uh i i got to tell you man
the the dumb stuff that comes out of the
olympics every like there's just
do you figure they do this like every
two years right there's a winter
olympics there's a summer olympics and
they just
can't figure it out like everywhere they
go they they leave
a wake of destruction in all of these
cities like they basically destroyed
brazil right like they just destroyed
the place well and even beijing they
build all these
you know venues and then they're never
used again like how many times do you
need a velodrome yeah right
yeah hey by the way what's your level of
interest in watching the olympics they
start this week
the opening ceremonies are friday listen
the other day i showed the gymnastics to
dylan and dylan didn't let me change the
channel huh hey
it was women's gymnastics i was so
impressed by my son it was one of those
moments where i'm like i'm proud of
everybody well
they kept saying leave it that leave it
that way i want to see it
avoid watching that marquee event so
that's good news for nbc has 7
000 hours of programming oh boy it's a
lot man
um what's the number you know their
profit in the last one picks was 250
million i thought their profit would be
a little bit higher
the the rights fees are probably about 3
billion per olympics i would imagine do
the athletes get paid
amateur isn't it no no no they're paid
now for sure no they could be
professionals not a big number though
yeah it's not a big number is it
sponsors how do what
what makes it worth four years of
training to swim
50 meters the elite or the gold medal i
mean
yeah the way gerard said what is it
worth me training four years to swim
50 meters you know that's a good point
you know what is it worth
are you kidding me yes cardboard beds
are you're serious
for the rest of your lifetime supply and
cardboard
and i'll be able to tell the story
there'll be no money and this year
and this year they get all consciousness
and this year they get to put on their
own medals as well
oh nice they're not waiting for anyone
to play look is that right
you know i'm not a look i i feel you
know
then this kind of goes against my my
entirety of uh
personal choice and and freedom on this
here we go
i got to tell you the people that don't
want to stand for the anthem like why
are you representing your country i
don't get that man
i that that like to me that's the
easiest opt out in the world
yeah the ioc said they're gonna punish
them if they do it we'll see because you
know what's going to happen
i mean these protests are already being
formulated in the minds of some of these
athletes
whatever yeah i look forward to watching
the world cup olympics i
there's a few events i actually like
okay and by the way you know what people
like usain bolt
you know you know that one scene with
the same bolt where the ladies talking
was like i'm sorry they're singing them
national anthem that's the national
anthem that was
awesome that's the kind of stuff that
you see and you're like by the way
he's a unifier yeah that's a man with
respect all these other guys that's the
kind of people that we need to see
rise up during janice janice refused to
uh
i just found out about this i sent you a
tweet he refused to
allow the bucks to make a t-shirt of him
dunking over booker yeah because he said
it was disrespectful to me i saw that
yeah i was like that's interesting
and he's talking about have you seen
they asked him they're like have you
seen the block he was like nah
living in the past is ego i'm gonna love
the tweet what i said about giannis
giannis to me
is the complete and i responded to
steven stephen a smithy i said i'm like
what are you talking about like
oh chris middleton should win mvp no he
shouldn't no
yeah and right there you just had it
right there i said uh
the nba needs a new face and giannis is
a total 180 the current phase
how do you not love this current guy
this guy's current attitude i hope he
doesn't change it the league will
attract new audiences and stop being as
divisive of a brand as it's been the
last few years
the guy who said it is a hardcore
left-wing guy
who said people forget giannis literally
jumped over tim hardwick jr and ali hoop
and then blocked the bucks from selling
a shirt about it because he thought it
was disrespectful
he's really like this and has always
been that guy needs to be to face it
well you know what i have to disagree
isn't that anti-capitalism right there
of not allowing a t-shirt i'm teasing
i'm joking i'd love to
make money off of it but let barstow
make money off of it yeah not this guy
this guy's already doing good for
himself pat i did make this point last
week and i stand by it tell me
i still don't think they're a shoe-in to
win this thing i think the sons are
gonna know i'm gonna tell you why my
son's homers
yeah you know what let's see what
happens when the pressure's on to make
free throws did you
by the way did you chris paul's comment
did your christmas comments yeah that
even he expects to miss some of you see
that's the kind of stuff why people
don't want to be your teammate what kind
of a comment is that i know yeah
he says you know even he doesn't think
he's going to make the [ __ ] he's playing
after you lose 3-2 what are you talking
about with 15 turnovers yeah but
let me pull a pbd here there's data out
there all right the sun shoot like 86
percent free throws
that's voters that's four to eight
points that could be a swing
in a possession by possession game these
last two i think it's going seven that's
my prediction
oh i don't think i i think it could go
seven but here's what i will tell you
if they don't win tonight it is a big
mistake because the last game they
barely won yeah if they don't win
tonight the bucks it is a
big big mistake they would be the first
team in nba history by the way
if what they would be the first team in
nba history to lose game
six at home up 3-2 really yes history
in the finals in the history of the
finals it would be the first time i'm
gonna do this last story before dream
team i gotta call in seven minutes so
yellen
sees several more months of rapid
inflation before easing worries about
housing
impact this is a cnbc story treasury
secretary janet yellen cautioned
thursday that prizes could continue to
rise for several more months
though she expects the recent start uh
start startling inflation run
to ease over time she added that she
worries about the problems
inflation could pose for lower income
families looking to buy homes at a time
where real estate values are surging the
consumer price index
which measures costs for a wide range of
items increased 5.4
in june the fastest pace in 13 years
excluding food and energy the gauge
rose 4.5 percent the fastest
acceleration in 30 years
also housing prices in the nation's
largest cities climb nearly 15 percent
the most recent measurements
though consumer survey points to
expectations of higher inflation ahead
yellen said she is encouraged by
market-based
measures that suggest prices will cool
over the long term so now
did you watch her being grilled by
kennedy yesterday i think it's senator
kennedy did you see did you see him
grill on orisa for like seven minutes
and 20 seconds okay
so he kept saying do you think inflation
is going to be higher by the end of the
year
she says uh if you look at it as a
12-monther
i don't think it's going to be i'm going
to ask you one more he asked five
different times she never answered it
then he brought up the federal reserve
and said i don't want to comment on that
but she did
he says listen the feds are kind of
saying that they may and the market
reacted to it
meaning they're going to increase the
rates and they're not going to wait till
2023. well no it was a technical
adjustment that they have to make she
kept saying right technical adjustment
that they have to make
then i go and listen to powell when
powers powell says
you don't come up with permanent uh
responses to temporary situations
meaning this is just a temporary
inflation
that is here we don't need to
permanently you know temporarily raise
the rates
today to make up for inflation right i
mean that's kind of what they're talking
about right now
but yellen is definitely not saying that
this is going to go down anytime soon
she's not sitting there fighting you
should say no it's going to be here
but it's going to taper off and go away
right we're going to see what's going to
happen what are your thoughts on this
well i was on your podcast about a month
ago and i remember i was talking about
janet yellen said that
inflation wasn't happening and joe biden
said no it's a one percent inflation
month over month it's one percent and
you're sitting here going what world are
they living in
what world are they living in they've
they've been lying to us the whole time
what would make you start thinking
they're telling the truth now like if
somebody trusts
anything the government's telling us at
this point i don't trust you
like i have more faith in conspiracy
theorists than i have in the government
at this point i have more faith
in those wet cardboard japanese beds
than i have in anything that comes out
of somebody in our
in our government's mouth doesn't it
seem like it's like the perfect storm
for high inflation
and there sure is a lot of talk about
not being inflation or there's going to
be inflation
and we're already starting to see it and
you said the market reflected it the
other day too it's coming there's no
question about it
i mean look there's even a supply chain
problem that's still affected you if you
wanted to buy a new car
right now i don't know if you could i
mean it is that difficult to find a new
car right now and they're selling them
20 000. i have a friend who owns
multiple dealerships
20k over over asking price in california
and people will pay for it for some of
them and they'll have literally no new
car
inventory it's all the chips it totally
is that's what it is so by the way
here's here's a what look
there's certain things that you have to
you almost need
side effects let me explain what i mean
by this if you eat
50 cheesecakes in a week and you don't
gain weight there's something wrong
let me say that one more time yeah if
you eat 50 cheesecakes
what's the side effect the side effect
is happiness you're going to gain weight
right if you eat 20 hot dogs in a span
of an hour
what's probably going to happen you're
going to borrow you're going to go
straight to the bathroom you're going to
barf
if you don't something's wrong with your
body let me let me say this one more
time
something is wrong with your body coming
for joey chestnut he's hard with this if
you take 20 shots of vodka and you don't
get drunk
your body's broken okay david that one's
for you yeah
so here's the point if you print
six and a half trillion dollars of money
okay you shut people down
you put 50 million restaurants out of
business 50 million employees out of
business 10 000 restaurants out of
business whatever the number is
if you do that and you give people free
money to stay home
while you're giving them stimulus
if it doesn't break it's broken already
there's something wrong with the body
meaning when you print
money inflation goes up when you keep
rates
low you can manipulate the market but
eventually you have to increase the
rates
the rates are going to go up or else
something is
broken the math if three times three is
no longer nine
there is something wrong with the
calculator the calculator is the
government system that we have today
something has to go sure it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen when it happens
i don't know but right now they're
trying to spin it on all this other
stuff thinking oh it's not going to
happen it's not going to happen it's
about to come so it's a bold face lie
when they say that it's not going to
happen right because there's no way
logically it couldn't it yeah but just
like every other lie they tell us tom
it's for our own good they don't they
don't want to run on the market
is what they don't want so it's for your
own good by the way
david come on grab the guitar three
lines david three lines uh
is that song public or no uh no no it's
not public no you can you can check out
my spotify but
it's that song that you did last night
public no it's not okay for
fair the fact that you've never played
that publicly
next week you have to play something for
us sure okay
all right by the way it's a great song
it's on instagram if you want to see it
hey
if you enjoyed today's podcast slam that
smash that subscribe
button we are 32 000 subs away
uh from uh reaching a hundred thousand
and on top of that
tom started to show tom take 30 seconds
to tell us about your podcast okay so
you graciously opened up the channel
valuetainment sports yes so sports fans
out there this is not
x's and o's and details of games this is
fun stuff this is pop culture sports
this is business sports
we're going to do an episode today
gerard's going to be on it so check out
our first one
it's at valuetainment sports is that
where they get a kai do they just put
the link below in the comment section
and in the description yeah you guys are
going to enjoy the show because
it's fun i'm always going to have great
guests we're going to keep this thing
moving it's going to be relevant it's
going to be timely it's going to
you know what i'm very opinionated when
it comes to sports but it's informed
opinion so you're going to get a lot of
that in that hour
let's see how gerard and i do today i'm
looking forward to it a couple more
rants from the big guy over here so
check us out
and uh this thing's going to grow and
grow and grow but you're going to enjoy
it so valuetainment sport it's called
sports
now
the host go subscribe gang we will do
this again
thursday we're on thursday same time
nine weeks take everybody bye
you